Alright we decided to do a walkthrough
video today where we put some audio over
the level as we play. This is Pepper Panic Saga
level 70, this is a level that a lot of
people have been getting stuck on lately
and we thought this might help to get people
through it
first thing you need to do is clear the
ice
and you see the different colors that are
frozen there. We'll start out with an L match
because those are always good. it's at the
bottom the board so that's also helpful
because other things happen as a result. in
the beginning you don't really have a
lot of choices so you just want to make
the move that's
basically going to clear the ice the
fastest
like I said in the beginning you really
don't have a lot of options the just
we do have one red pepper that three now
but there's not enough other red peppers
out there
like exploded but that one that actually
clear out the
other read that was on the ice
move the things that hard about this
level is the you know it's fifty moos
you get close a lot New Year as easy be
appropriate to you
you want to make sure that your thinking
about why me he threw its really
we really like this level actually but
I'm
I was we played a lot of time
are the
the thing about it is you not really
going to get lucky
when you're playing this in this
accidentally finish the level
so that kinda level so yet to look for
situations where you came
actually set to move the if you read the
guide you know that
we talk about setting up the
tease in the aisles and for paper
matches
gorham right now you can see we are the
two green above
this one that would
could make the shockwave so
a simple for you
but we also store clearly I so
readers can continue growing peppers who
you are word pops up all weekend
or were know that that's that its power
in
word F lee Ermey cover colmer so we can
directly make the shop where those are
the ones you want to look for all the
time you see here to curl
to cover the same color next to us that
you you want to see if there's any
possible way that you can bring one down
and create shockwave here you see we
have yellow sitting next to
for the statues lawyer on the middle
though so I don't know if we can
grow those there's another one
we definitely take the his soon
to the comes up you know all the ice is
clear that searchers gone
oranges with or there that they're more
orange than anything else
Nexus searches but the it's not really a
position where we can actually
getting over that the room with her
here Armour CEO because that puts the
state's five separate next to the
that too that's already damaged so no
the exploder a green pepper ago because
it to them there's a star
though there was that his we might get
the word
we got the green to that's good doesn't
like a really old
or 830 shot way over the top good
we have to read words at the top lower
will receive the care something now
there's nothing really in this column
so
remove this will remove the rednecks to
it there
but it also lets throw the top and at
the same thing so
I wasn't necessarily a good move but
there are times when you just don't
really have a good move
all that worked out
we don't have any any shock wave that we
can set up
we have
orange my to the searchers the restroom
mixed up
here we can make that word from
mess it up a little earlier lead to a
shockwave like to
explosion earlier chain reaction to a
I think cleared out this column will be
better fewer
fall yell things and
same thing here i mean
we're getting closer view explode or but
dropping
peppers is never a bad thing and the
only thing unfortunately that happens
sometimes as we
start by preparing Carino really mean it
again me I kinda bad job here we don't
know
a shockley mirth
we have a new staff were moved yet those
who were doing pretty good
exploding rather be there the best color
looks like we
might be able to get in there so with
this
work on that for now and see what
happens
we do have one day one dream next to the
search user
wanna learn to earn Treasury oranges
still occur like two minutes the red
though
meant to the top like him I get us to
head to fit
I don't think it
well let's see
there's not really a better mood with
her yes %uh that's fine
looks like the one on the bottom right
is going to be the hardest one person
yet earlier
the here either so
know we have the to read here by this
that here in the gaps already in place
for
we could miss the yellow
in there but it won't drop it as far as
we need to go
this is interesting because what we have
to 5 ever matches that we can make
but I think it's better to skip it
because we can definitely hit the
it the one on the left with the larger
we dropped the we just make a regular 3
per minute later
one of the reasons for clearing the
other rowers because we still have those
who read sitting
there's we can try to bring the other as
that the
or as an hour back to work star early or
anything
to the right next to you that weaker
work
from mention the Greens find could be
that's next were the big statue the red
obviously is slightly better but
it wasn't available and
when you use our paper panic where can
you don't lose your lose any
like big papers its fine
to do so now we're
at seventy moves only have
we r
a good setup but we do you have
perimeter set something up
years growing the right approach the the
best way to go
at this point here we make this for
paper were actually im
make a I'm you'll get those two red ones
together
that work out for at
that's the way you you go to work think
about it with that's pretty hard to
figure out where they can actually end
up
you religious near to what looks like
it'll work out the best
moved with her
were a little bit stuck in there also
were just for movies we have these two
orange hear the words above but there's
no in a way to drop
anything below it so what what we do
there's we're hoping that we could drop
a red and because any college football
there
reading we got yellow instead but that
would have been
your helpful your we are able to
third reaction
mmm with him in a crisp buttery make it
you know there are far away from each
other so all you have to do is move
things around the years and see what
happens
others who will be mad at the other girl
here
its likely you get the red
alright so this is really like where
this level and up
most the time we need two hits we have
so this is where you have to like even
though it's been all
you burned like
you see if I manage these green at the
bottom
after a match the now the orange was
gonna for ordering that one down
its gonna have the oath to re-emerge
the to drop the Orange Order the place
to start
for sure with her let's agree infers
learned SEO
the other soldier up there then that's
one word mill
the Greens rate there but we can get
here
were we can do is we can make the shock
wave with a greener
tar it the to an old
blow to move out of the way early
they're both days prior to birth
exterior their ears for in
a whole
I was almost good know this drop another
one down and see what happened to me
with there's no
clear-cut best thing to do here with
maginnis trees at the top there really
were going
but reformers are like me lol actually
blow that up
normally so again here
sleek think we go with the shock wave
again because it'll grow the to bring
was below it may set of something above
that would give us to where we're
were close to explore researcher him as
the green purse because I'm a loser
her shock wave going down with me that
workers
hope for the best
order you agree merger a
for her
that I do it you you display a movie
diversification and
to North Face little help from the
papers but
you can get you can beat it like you
said we do like this I will because the
key in
you do have control it's not based
completely on lucky you know
and we're sure that you can be a tedious
have to take your time and
find those moves a make sure you take a
second to like us on Facebook
there's a the Like buttons on the right
hand side the review
updates and check back regularly we're
always adding new content
thanks for taking our video hope will
help you get through the level
girl